Thanks for having me on.
>> All right, so I need to I need to be
clear. I need to cuz I I don't
understand. Do you believe that Jesus is
one in essence with the father?
>> Okay, so this is this is a great way to
start. Um let's go straight to your
example where you have an equation with
terms on the left. 2 + 2 is equal to 4,
right? And I'm assuming that on four you
mean God by essence, right?
>> Yes.
>> Okay. So you hold to classical theism,
divine simplicity, right?
>> I guess so. I'm not I'm not who you
philosophy buff.
>> Okay. Okay. So So basically that is to
say God is simple. He's not made of
parts in his essence. Right. So all of
his attributes are fully actual and the
same all the time. And so that means
that if there is a hypothesis, so
another person that possesses the divine
essence, it has to possess all the same
attributes in full like in complete
equality. Right?
>> Okay.
>> Right. So that means that you're
limiting the left side of the terms to
the same expression in every sense
because under classical theism, every
term has to be the same if it's grounded
in essence, right? So you can't have
like 1 + 3 is equal to 4 and then 2 + 2
is equal to 4 under classical theism
where it's grounded in essence. So the
way that I would explain it and I want
to get into the early church fathers in
the apostolic era. So Justin Martyr, St.
Arus, um Tation and things like that and
prove that um eternal generation is
actually not necessary to prove the
divinity of the sun and it actually
undermines how the Bible uses the term
God. So
>> So I'm just to just to slow you down. So
I I still don't know your position.
That's like So look, try
>> I'll define God for you. I'll define God
for you. This will be the easiest way.
>> No, please just let me let me tell you
how I can understand. Okay.
>> Sure.
>> Talk to me as if you're talking to
somebody who did not go to, you know,
preliminary school and stuff like that.
I'm a simple guy.
>> I'm a I'm a regular dude, bro.
>> Okay. So this is this is the easiest way
to explain.
>> So let's define God then. So glad in the
scriptures
>> I'm asking I'm asking do you believe
that Jesus shares the same substance is
of the same substance in essence as the
father.
>> Yes. And I'm going to explain why it's
different and why it's important. Okay.
So because of na we express
trinitarianism through essence not
relation. So God is a relational term.
So it is a concrete personal noun of
relation that designates sovereignty
over a sphere. So God the father is
almighty God. The son of God is lord
over all creation and have sovereignty
over creation. Angels and demons have
limited delegated authority and are
called gods. Elohim in the old
testament. Moses judges of Israel are
called Elohim gods. And the um domain
sphere in the language that is similar
in all these is sovereignty.
>> Okay. Do you believe that Jesus is
created?
>> No. So this again this is a language
thing.
>> So the scriptures
>> really quick because I'm I'm asking very
simple questions to understand your
position.
>> He is begotten
>> but not made.
>> So you believe so you believe that Jesus
eternally existed with the father. Never
came into existence but has always
existed. Is that correct?
>> No. So that's that's where we depart. So
you apologist.
>> No. No. So if you trace the language
throughout the scriptures from old
testament to new testament there are two
word families that described origin.
Okay. So when you say to beget something
and when you say to create something the
mode of origin for those two words is
different. Right. So fathers beget sons
out of their own substance. Correct.
>> Yeah. But you're saying that Jesus did
not always exist with the father but is
also not. So you believe that Jesus came
into existence but
>> he had an origin. Correct.
>> But is not created.
>> That is that is correct. Because created
is a different term
>> because so part of the problem is in
semantics Jehovah Witnesses and
Unitarians and all that for a long time
have conflated beetting with creating
because they share origin. But mode of
origin matters in the Bible. So gino to
be get is the same word that describes
progeny producing children all the way
through. It is limited to that category
only. Kidzo which is the Greek word to
create is used for artifacts and things
like that all the time who come into
existence.
>> I'm going to be I'm going to show you
>> I'm going to be real with you. This
isn't the live for this because you're
you're trying to like uh I'm I'm this is
one more way.
>> This is for a discussion to to gauge and
you're like going like dictionary.
>> Let's try let's try one more way. I'm
asking you. So
>> let's try one more way. Okay.
>> Okay. How how is
>> how is the sun? How is the sun uncreated
but came into existence? Help me
understand that.
>> Okay. So I just defined two different
word categories, right? To create
something means to bring an artifact
into existence from nothing. To be means
to produce something from yourself from
one kind to another kind.
>> You can also create something from
something too. It doesn't
>> right and that's artifact creation.
Whereas personal generation is always
beginning. And so what I want to get
into is that
>> when you when you create when you create
hold on a second when you create
something it comes into existence right
that's what it means to create something
is that right
>> so you can say it either comes into
existence in its form right so you could
take pre-existing material and form it
so God took man from the dust and he
formed them
>> be very simple when you create something
that something comes into existence is
that correct or not
>> right Okay.
>> Right. And when someone is begotten,
they come into existence. Correct.
>> No, not in Jesus's case. Because
>> well, you're just special pleading a
definition that the early church fathers
never do.
>> I'm not. They said they say time and
before creation, right?
>> No, they don't say before time. They say
before creation. There's a distinction
there.
>> That's where So, you don't you believe
time is is eternal and infinite.
>> No, I believe time is a measurement of
God's action. Right. When we when we
describe time, it's action in motion.
>> All right, brother. I I appreciate it.
I'm I'm going to go ahead and let
somebody else up, man. My goodness. All
right. So, go ahead, Muhammad. What's
your question?
>> Yeah. So, like, what's your problem with
Islam? Like, why do you target only
Islam? Why not any other religion? Why
do you make uh daily live streams just
about Islam?
>> God called me to deal with Islam.
>> How?
>> By giving you guys the truth of the
gospel. by showing you that you've been
deceived.
>> Like why not uh insulting any other
religion? Judaism.
>> I don't insult any religion. I just
expose it.
>> So why only expose Islam then?
>> I don't only expose Islam. I expose
other religions too. But I mainly expose
Islam cuz that's what God has called me
for mostly.
>> So like uh what like what aspects of
Islam like if I solve it for you, you
would accept Islam like?
>> Sure. Yeah. So, um,
the biggest thing for me is that Islam
makes a claim about my scriptures, about
the Torah and the Gospel. It says that
Muhammad is found in the Torah and the
Gospel. If you can show me that Muhammad
is in the Torah and the Gospel, I
definitely believe that he was a
prophet, but unfortunately, he's not in
there. That's why I reject Islam. That's
the main reason why I reject it. There's
other reasons, but that's the biggest
thing for me. You there?
>> Yes. So I'm saying that we Muslims
believe that Torah is corrupted and you
also know that and the Bible is just
it's just a man-made version of the like
the Torah like they did it for their own
like benefit something.
>> Wait, I'm sorry. Say it again.
>> Like I'm saying Torah is corrupted
according to us Muslims. The only book
that's not corrupted is Quran.
>> You said the Torah is corrupt.
>> Yes. Every other book before the Quran.
We believe in in those books but we
believe that they are corrupted.
>> How can you say you believe in a book
but believe it's corrupted at the same
time? Like I believe that that those
words
like like
or yes
but but they are they are corrupt and
Quran final
prophet
>> and for the last of the
>> So when the Quran says that it came
confirming the Torah and the gospel what
you're really mean to say is that he
came confirming corrupted false books.
>> Yes.
>> So Allah is confirming corrupted false
books saying that these false books are
true.
>> They are not true. But they like they
are true in a sense that they were
revealed to the prophets but they were
corrupted by those people for their own
like benefit.
>> But it says that it's true in that time
in Muhammad's time like when when would
you say that the Torah and Gospel got
corrupted? like just in in 100 years
after Jesus was born or maybe even less
than that.
>> Got it. So before Muhammad became a
prophet, they were already corrupted.
>> Yes.
>> So then Allah then sends the Quran down
saying that he sent the Quran confirming
the Torah and Gospel that's with them.
They had a corrupted Torah and Gospel,
but the Quran is confirming their to
their corrupted Torah and Gospel. Is
that right?
>> Yes.
>> So he's saying that corrupted books are
true.
>> Corrupted books. No brother, see
corrupted books are not true. Like they
have
>> Allah says that that's the point.
>> Where does it say?
>> Okay. Do you know what it means to
confirm something?
>> Mhm.
>> When you confirm when you confirm
something, you're saying that that thing
is true. So when the Quran says it
confirms the scriptures that's with the
Jews and Christians, it's saying that
the scriptures they have are true.
>> No, it does not say that. It says that
it confirms the scriptures in a sense
that they were revealed in their pure
form but later they were corrupted.
>> It doesn't say it confirms the
scriptures with them. That's all it
says.
>> Which Can you like tell me the ayah of
the Quran?
>> Yeah. This chapter 2:41.
>> So it says believe in my revelations
which confirm your scriptures. Do not be
the first to deny them or trade them for
a fleeting gain. Yeah, that's like the
Quran also says this. Do not be the
first to deny them or trade them for a
fleeting gain and be mindful of me. So
he's referring to the people who
corrupted those scriptures.
>> No, he doesn't say that they corrupted
it. He says that they have the truth of
them and he's telling them not to
abandon them. Do not trade them for a
fleeting gang. Do not mix them with
falsehood. He's warning them not to do
that. So the scriptures they have are
good. The Quran confirms them. Meaning
it's saying that they're true. Don't
abandon them. Right?
Like which scriptures?
>> The Torah and the Gospel.
>> No, it's not mentioned Torah and Gospel.
>> All right. What scriptures are there
with them? Immas's time. What scriptures
did the Quran come confirming?
>> It didn't come confirming any
scriptures. It uh like it was a new book
revealed.
>> Read chapter 3. Go to chapter 3. Read
verse 3 and 4. How do we reach these
keys? So he has revealed to you oh
prophet the book of book book in truth
confirming what came before it as he
reveals the Torah and the gospel.
>> All right stop there.
>> Yes.
>> So he re the Quran came down confirming
what exactly?
>> He revealed to you prophet the book in
confirming what came before it
>> which was
>> as the Torah and the gospel. Yes.
>> Very good.
>> So the Quran came confirming the Torah
and Gospel. Right.
>> Yes. It came confirming in a sense that
Allah like corrected those books
>> like those books contains the same
message as
>> that Allah is one.
>> That's right. According to the Quran,
it's in line with the Torah and Gospel
in its theology in the prophet message
of the prophets.
>> Yeah. Not the Bible, the pure form of
Torah and gospel. The pure form which
was corrupted.
>> No worries. So the Quran came confirming
saying that the Torah and Gospel is
true. Right.
>> Yes.
>> Okay.
>> According to the Quran, according to the
Quran, did the Jews and Christians have
the Torah and Gospel with them in
Muhammad's time?
>> Yes. But they were in their corrupted
form.
>> Okay. So they're in their corrupted
form. Let me go with you and show you
how bad that is.
>> So I'm not sure like this goes like you
can. Yeah, let's go with this first
claim that they were in their corrupted
form, right? They were in their
corrupted form. Okay, so in Muhammad's
time, they're in their corrupted form
with the Jews and Christians. However,
the Quran comes and says there the Quran
comes and says that it came down believe
in what we what I have sent down talking
about the Quran confirming that which is
with you. So the Quran came confirming
what the Jews and Christians have with
them, right?
>> Yes.
>> Awesome. What do they have with them?
The Torah and Gospel, right?
>> No, but this would like Why would the
Quran make like such a claim?
>> Because you're obviously misinterpreting
it.
>> I don't, brother. I'm I'm going to be
real with you. As real as I can be, I
don't have to interpret anything. The
only thing that I do is read. The only
thing that I'm going to do for you, bro,
is I'm going to read you verbatim what
the Quran says. I'm not going to add to
it at all. I don't have to. It did all
the work for me. The only thing we do
around here is we just read. That's it.
So, I'm giving you the quoting what they
say.
>> Even if I Okay. If even if I listen to
your case, so then why was the Quran
revealed like
>> that? And there it is. That's the
dilemma. the Quran according to look
>> if I'm if I'm going to be charitable.
>> No, if I I'm not accepting your case.
I'm like
>> don't accept my case. Talk about the
Quran.
>> Don't accept my case. Talk about the
Quran. It's either you accept the Quran
or you don't. You believe the Quran,
right?
>> Yes.
>> You love the Quran.
>> You would never add to the Quran or take
away from it.
>> No.
>> You would never mix the Quran.
>> It's impossible. It's impossible.
>> Good. So you would never mix the Quran
with falsehood, right?
>> No, it's impossible as it's in the
hearts of millions.
>> It's in the hearts, right? That's right.
It's in my heart, too. Okay. So, I'm
giving you what the Quran says. I'm
hoping you believe it. The Quran says in
chapter 2:41, remember the first verse I
showed you? Believe in what I sent down
confirming that which is with you.
Right?
>> Believe in what I sent down confirming
confirming. Then after
>> confirming what is with you.
>> What is with you? Okay.
>> What did they have with them that the
Quran is saying is true?
>> Okay. Which I added as surah 2 ay 41.
>> Yes.
>> No. Here it just says believe in my
relations which confirm your scriptures.
Do not be the first to deny them or
trade them for a fleeting.
>> So they're scriptures. The Quran is
saying are true. Right.
>> Well, let me read this.
>> What do you need to read the taps for?
When the Quran is very clear on what it
says. What do you What do you need with
this?
>> No, you were clearly misinterpreting it
because
>> Did I say anything that was not in the
verse?
>> No, maybe like from Arabic to English,
it can be a little distorted the
translation.
>> That's fine and all, but can you
acknowledge that I'm only saying what
the verse says, right?
>> Yes.
>> So, I don't need I'm not interpreting
anything. I'm just literally saying what
the verse says. So, the verse says that
the scriptures they have is true, right?
the scriptures they have pro like if
this is the case why would the Quran be
revealed
>> let's talk about that after let's first
get this admission the verse itself says
that the scriptures they have is true
right
>> well there are some people who were
still on the path of Isaam
>> I don't care about
>> during the time of the prophet
>> so
>> I need you to listen to my question okay
>> I do not care about the people who are
guided or misguided that has nothing to
do with the books themselves, right? For
example, if there were Muslims who were
misguided, like let's say for example,
Ahmedi Muslims, right? Um, who believe
in another messenger after Muhammad
comes after Muhammad, you would say that
they're misguided, right?
>> Does that mean the Quran is corrupted?
Just because you have a group of Muslims
that are misguided?
>> No.
>> Right. So, just because people may be
misguided doesn't have anything to do
with the book itself. So I'm only
focusing on the book itself, not the
people. Okay. Okay. So according to what
the Quran says regarding the books
themselves, it says it's confirming the
scriptures that's with them.
>> Yes.
Correct.
>> Yes. Here is written that there was a
prophecy of the prophet Muhammad in
their scriptures which they told to the
people but they didn't believe out of
arrogance. They didn't like
>> So it's saying that the scriptures they
have are true, right? No, not fully
true.
>> Where does it Wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. What does
it say?
>> Some truths in.
>> No, hold on. Does it say here that it's
confirming part of their scriptures or
does it just simply say generally just
making a basic general claim, it's
confirming their scriptures? Does it say
it's confirming part of the scriptures
or some of it?
>> No, just the scriptures.
>> So, notice how in order for you to hold
to your belief, you have to add to the
Quran. I don't stop adding to the Quran.
Please don't do it. Do not add to the
Quran.
>> I'm not adding.
>> So then don't say what the Quran does
not say.
>> Do not say what the Quran does not say.
Okay.
>> No, I am reading the taps. Okay.
>> Forget the taps. Let's read the verse.
We can understand that verse. We got
comprehension. Let's let's focus on the
verse. The verse is very clear when it
says confirming the scriptures that's
with them. Right? So the scriptures
that's with them are true, right?
>> No, like uh I'm not sure what do the
common Muslims say about this. Like
>> I don't
>> I do not care. Who do you take? Allah or
the or the common Muslim? Who should we
take?
>> Of course, Allah. But the people of
knowledge in Islam, what do you say
about this?
>> Depends on who you ask. If you ask Bkari
and Ibn Abbas, the Torah and the Gospel
are exactly as Allah revealed them with
no letter change. If you ask other
scholars like Iba and others, they think
that the Torah and Gospel have been
textually corrupted. So it depends on
which people you go to, they're not.
They they al they say different things
on this.
>> Okay.
>> So regardless of what the scholars say
or the common Muslims say, let's revert
back to what Allah says himself in his
book. And in his book, it's very clear.
It's very straightforward. It's very
explicit that the scriptures they have
with them are true. Right? If we just go
with what the verse says.
>> Okay.
>> Awesome. Now with that being said, now
the question is then what is the point
of the Quran then? Right? That was the
next question. If these scriptures are
still true even in the Quran's time,
then why what what's the point of the
Quran? Right? H
>> I'm going to give you a Quranic point of
view cuz I'm going to be honest with the
Quran and then I'm going to give you my
objection. Okay? So I'm going to be fair
to the Quran and give you internally
what the Quran says it's revealed for.
One,
>> okay,
>> it's revealed so that the people in
Arabia cannot have uh can cannot have an
excuse. They can't say, "Oh, Allah
didn't give us what he gave to the Jews
and Christians, right? how he gave them
scriptures. He didn't give us scripture.
So on the day of judgment,
>> why would they when uh like make an
excuse?
>> Say that again.
>> Like why would they even make an excuse?
They were following their their
religions like worshiping idols.
>> Yeah. But they would say they would say,
"Allah, you never told us like you never
gave us a revelation. You never gave us
a scripture uh correcting us like you
did with the Jews and Christians. You
never gave us a scripture." So they
would try to use this excuse against
them on on judgment day. You get what
I'm saying?
>> Yes. Yeah. That's part of the reason the
Quran was that.
>> Yep. So that's one reason believe this.
>> Okay.
>> Exactly. That's one reason. So according
to the Quran, that's one reason why the
Quran is revealed to eliminate any
excuse that these pagans would have. You
can't say that Allah didn't tell you.
You can't say that he didn't send a
messenger to you and give you a
revelation. You can't say he didn't do
that cuz he did. All right? That's
number one. Number two is to fulfill and
confirm the previous scriptures. So the
previous scriptures foretell this coming
of the Arab messenger and Allah in the
and the Quran, Allah revealing the
Quran. So the Quran is supposed to be a
fulfillment and a completion of Allah's
revelations. It's supposed to be that
final complete revelation that Allah
seals the deal with. Like this is it.
Okay, that's number two. Um,
I feel like I'm forgetting another
reason, but for the most part, those are
the two main reasons why I that I
remember that the Quran talks about.
Okay, now here's my objection. Okay, my
objection to this is is that the Quran
is not a revelation. It's not. It's a
man-made book. The reason why it's not a
revelation is because of the standard
that it sets itself. It says, like I
told you, it's supposed to be a
completion of the previous scriptures.
It's supposed to be in line and a
fulfillment of them, right?
>> However, it's not. When we look at the
Torah and we look at the gospel, the
Quran and Muhammad are nowhere
mentioned. Islam is nowhere.
>> No, it's mentioned in the Torah. That's
the Jews already prophesized.
>> No, it's not. It's nowhere in the Torah.
But we get like the narrations of a
sahhabi Salman al- Fari. He got he got
to know about the prophet from a Jew.
Like not from a Jew but a Christian
somewhat Christian that a prophet is
coming in Medina so you can meet him.
>> Yeah. There's nowhere in the Torah that
says that. Nothing in the Torah says
that at all. That's that's made up
>> because the Torah is corrupted. The
Torah
>> not according to the Quran. The Quran
doesn't say the Torah is corrupted. It
says it's true. the Torah. No, at the
time of the prophet.
>> Yeah. At the time of the prophet, the
Torah was still good to go, right?
>> Well, we have the manuscripts that date
not just in the time of Muhammad, but
even way before that, hundreds of years
before Muhammad. We have those
manuscripts. We have the Torah that
existed hundreds of years before
Muhammad. So, the Torah we have is still
good according to the Quran. And he's
nowhere mentioned in the Torah.
>> Okay? If you want to check that out one
day, look up what the Dead Sea Scrolls
are. The Dead Sea Scrolls, that's the
Old Testament, that's the Torah and
other writings of the prophets, uh,
found even a few a few hundred years
before Jesus. Like they're they date to
a few hundred years before Jesus, almost
200 years before Jesus. And we have
those scrolls.
>> So you you see you see the issue here.
So the Quran says that the Torah is true
even in Muhammad's time. It's true. It
confirms it.
>> But however,
It wasn't fully like like the parts of
divine guidance existed but like people
>> what you need to do
>> remember notice how human is
>> notice what we said Muhammad notice what
we said we're not going to add to the
Quran we're not going to say something
that the Quran does not say are we in
agreement with that
>> no but if we look at the hadith
>> that's not what I'm asking you are we in
agreement just answer this real quick
and you can say what you were about to
say.
>> Yes, we can.
>> Are we in agreement that we will not add
to the Quran?
>> Yes, that's Muslim rules. We follow
>> the Muslim rule. So, don't add to the
Quran. Does the Quran anywhere say that
only part of the Torah is revelation
that the Torah in Muhammad's time only
contains part or some revelation? Does
the Quran say
>> have you like what if you look at the
Arabic the Arabic words?
>> Yeah. Does the Quran ever say that? The
answer is no. It never says that. Matter
of fact, let me let me show you. Go to
go to chapter 2 verse 85. Sarah Bakarra,
go to chapter 2. Go to verse 85. It's
going to say the opposite of what of
what you're trying to say. You're trying
to say that the Torah, part of it was
good, right? We can believe in part of
the Torah at that time. The Quran verse
is going to say the opposite. Watch. Go
ahead and read verse chapter 2 vers 85.
>> Do you believe in some of the scripture
and reject the rest? Is there any reward
for those who do soul among you other
than disgrace in this worldly life
against harvest punishment day of
judgment?
>> You see,
>> it says the exact opposite of what you
of what you said, right? Do you believe
in part of the scripture and reject the
rest? Those who do so will be disgraced
in this life and a severe torment waits
for them in the hereafter.
>> Which scripture? It just says scripture.
>> Yes. So I mean you can't do that with
any of his scripture. The Torah is
scripture. The gospel is scripture. The
Quran is supposedly scripture. You
cannot pick and choose what parts of the
scripture you believe in. You have to
believe in all of it.
>> But what if this is addressing to the
people of that time when the scripture
was all correct.
>> Good. So this would mean that in the 7th
century in Muhammad's time the Torah was
all correct. Right? And my point is is
that we have that Torah. We have even
the Torah before that. That's my point.
We have the correct Torah. Even by the
Quran standards, the Torah we have is
not after Muhammad. It's before Muhammad
>> and during Muhammad.
>> Okay. So like tell the argument for
what's your argument then?
>> So my argument is is that according to
the Quran, the Torah and the Gospel, the
previous scriptures are fully intact.
They are authoritative and they are
preserved. Okay.
>> How does this uh disprove Islam?
Excellent. So, the way that this
disproves Islam is because the Quran is
supposed to be in line with the Torah
and the Gospel. Muhammad is supposed to
be mentioned in the Torah and the
Gospel, but the Quran contradicts the
Torah and the Gospel. Muhammad is not
mentioned in the Torah and Gospel like
the Quran says.
>> So, therefore, the Quran is false. one
for not being in line with the Torah
gospel for contradicting them and also
for lying about what they say that
Muhammad's mentioned in them when he's
not
>> okay so can this can be misinterpreted
like they I am sure like there would be
many like very valid explanations for
this by the people of knowledge in Islam
but what if we looked at the other side
uh there are many scientific facts in
the Quran and many prophecies done by
the prophet about the future
How would you look at that,
>> brother? There is no explanation for
this. There's no look as you see this
and we're going through this together
and be honest with me. I'm going to ask
you again. Have I said anything that is
not literally in what the Quran says?
>> No, but you are like playing with the
words or something
>> or something. Come on, Mohammed.
Muhammad Mo, come on. Come on.
>> No, I mean why don't Okay. Okay. What if
you just put this at the side and look
at the other things? I can't
>> I'm not like disagreeing with you on
that.
>> Okay.
>> Like I'm not sure about it. Okay. But
like look at the other things. The facts
the scientific facts in the Quran. What
about that?
>> Sure. So we'll put we'll we'll put the
Islamic dilemma right there. So now
let's debug something else. How else is
the Quran false? Okay. So you're saying
that the Quran gets some scientific
facts correct, right? Is that right?
Okay. And you're saying that like some
are like not proven yet, but that
doesn't mean that they are wrong. So
yes.
>> Wait, what?
>> Some of the facts aren't proven like
they aren't scientifically proven yet.
So that so all of them are correct.
>> Right. So um the fact that the Quran got
some scientific facts correct shows that
it's a revelation from God. Right.
>> The one so far that we've discovered. So
>> signs Jesus signs. Yes. So then that
would mean that the reverse is true.
That if the Quran got some things
scientifically incorrect that we know
are incorrect, right? Then that would
mean that the Quran is not from God. Is
that right?
>> Yes.
>> Okay. So let me show you something.
>> But this is impossible. So even if
someone says it's scientifically
incorrect, it's either their lack of
knowledge, lack of research, or uh
they're just misinterpreting the words.
>> You see that? You see how you switched?
It's
Just present me the examples. Present
>> I will make a
>> but just but just notice how you already
laid the groundwork to not accepting
when the Quran gets it wrong. If the
Quran is wrong, it's not really the
Quran that's wrong, but that the person
is just misunderstanding something or
they got their facts incorrect or
something is going on with them. They're
just something is it's not the Quran
though. The Quran is right no matter
what. You see how you've already
>> that's our belief. Like we can't change
that.
>> Yeah. But I I I know you believe that,
but logically that's not how reality
works, right? In reality, if the Quran
gets something factually wrong, it's not
the facts fault that the Quran is wrong.
The Quran is just wrong. Okay? We're
talking about objectivity here. Okay?
>> What what if it's the lack of research?
Because for example in the ancient times
people believed the earth the sun
revolves around the earth and today we
believe that the earth revolves around
the sun. So that's what I'm talking.
>> So notice how bad this is. What if we
haven't done enough research yet to
where it seems like the Quran got some
things right but really it didn't. We
just haven't researched enough to know
that it got these things wrong. You see
how it could go both ways?
>> Yeah it can. So that would mean that
scientific accuracies are not a standard
by which you can say, "Yeah, this is a
revelation from God." Because if it
doesn't work one way, it doesn't work
the other way. If it's good enough to
prove the Quran, then it's good enough
to disprove it. But if you're saying
that scientific accuracies don't prove
the uh don't if you're saying that
scientific inaccuracies don't disprove
the Quran, then that means scientific
accuracies don't prove the Quran. It
doesn't work. No,
>> but you are trying to like make this
like present some examples.
>> Why scientific facts?
>> Will it prove the Quran wrong?
>> No. Like uh for example, mountains are
like pecks.
>> If I show the Quran,
>> if I show you I got you. If I show you a
scientific inaccuracy,
will that prove the Quran wrong?
>> Inaccuracy.
>> Yes. If the Quran, if the Quran makes a
claim,
>> If the Quran makes a claim and that
claim is scientifically incorrect,
>> would that mean that the Quran is false?
>> Yes.
>> All right, let's do it. Now,
>> if the scientific fact is really full
fully researched, there's no doubt in
it.
>> Okay. So,
>> but it's impossible like you can't
>> Let's see. Let's see. Let's see. What
was what was uh according to science,
what came first, the universe or the
earth?
>> Universal what?
>> The universe or the earth? The heavens
or the earth? What was what came first?
>> The universe. The big bang. The universe
of force.
>> Got it. So, and you would say it's a
fact, right? That the earth came and was
made after the universe after the
heavens.
>> Yes. But
>> still there's there can be more research
done on this. Okay. You see, that's why
this is a waste of time cuz all once you
see that it's that the Quran gets it
wrong. Oh, maybe there can be more
research.
>> Like, show the example. I'm not like I
>> It's a waste of time. I'm not going to
waste my time showing the example when
it doesn't do anything.
>> You were trying to avoid it. Like trying
to avoid it.
>> I'm trying to do what?
>> You were trying to avoid it.
>> I'm trying to man get off my stage. Get
off my stage. Go be a Muslim, bro. Full
Muslim. Get off the stage. I'm trying to
avoid it. I'm trying to avoid it. Ladies
and gents, get off my stage. Go watch
your head. You Y'all see this religion?
You see how this how dumb this religion
makes you? You see how dumb this
religion makes you? I'm trying to avoid
it when you yourself just came up and
said the Quran is right no matter what.
Doesn't matter what you show me. The
Quran gets scientific scientific things
right. If somebody brings an example
that the Quran got something
scientifically wrong. That just means
that there could be more research to be
done. So it wouldn't prove the Quran
false if it got something wrong. It just
means we don't know how right it is yet.
That means the reverse is true. Num
nuts. that if if it seemingly appears
that the Quran got something
scientifically correct, we can there
there could be more research to be done
to demonstrate that the Quran actually
got this wrong in reality. Dumb
religion. Dummies. Good grief.